[Music]
what once again he will tell you he said
you know what this Perseus guy is half
man and half God
you know he's kind of confused he
doesn't know what's going on and all
this stuff that's like a Jesus that's
Jesus fully man fully God came as a
human is Hollywood changing the idea of
the Gospel of Jesus Christ
find out on this episode of LED live
thank you
[Music]
light is exposing Darkness hello
everybody this is LED light exposing
darkness and this is little life Studios
every week we have this show going live
and we had discussion today about how
Hollywood is changing the Gospel of
Jesus Christ and we're going to have
this conversation and it's kind of like
a Bible study I just want to share with
you guys something a little bible study
and maybe it's gonna be a a few punches
maybe you're going to be like hey Alex
what are you talking about just oh good
hang in there and we're gonna be sharing
with you guys uh starting we're gonna be
uh the Bible the Bible Matthew 24 14.
the Bible said in this gospel the
kingdom will be preaching and all the
world as a witness to all the nation and
then the end will come I'm sure you guys
read this verse in the Bible before uh
it's very powerful no I mean it's
something like okay in what time we're
living and what time we're leaving and
I'm sure you guys heard like hey let's
share the gospel right let's share the
gospel so the end will come is going to
come and so we go go to heaven right I
mean the new Earth and all the stuff you
know as a Christian we believe that I
think we're living in a time like no
other where we can preach the gospel to
the world I mean we're sitting here on
in computers talking to thousands of
people around the world you could never
do that before right we've got to be
getting close yeah yeah so I have a
question for you guys and this verse in
Matthew 24 14 it has a word that I want
to ask you guys why do you think and
that verse it says
as a witness you know all these gospel
is going to be preaching right and the
whole world as a witness to All Nations
I think something has to be demonstrated
to the world like the gospel is not just
a
a theory but actually to see it in
Practical use
yeah it's interesting because it's a
phrase uh I've learned you know English
is my second language so I learned this
thing actions it speaks louder than
words that's right so it's kind of
interesting that word because if you
take that word out like witnessing I
mean you can read it you know I mean it
sounds very nice but it seems like the
Lord said you know what no let's put
that word there as a witness because
it's so important that like you were
saying like you know we need to show
that we have you know we hang out with
Jesus right it's an example exactly
examples so I just want to also notice
that in the beginning of that verse
it says in this gospel
why it says degaspo what do you think it
has to work
t-h-i-s there must be uh there must be
another gospel out there counterfeit
gospel interesting uh
when um
like I said you know learning a second
language and that word about and this
gospel you know this uh if I ask you
Scotty uh give me a DVD
can you please give me a DVD
no I don't want this one
no I don't want this one you know what I
really want that one is called so
duology The Art of Lying
so what he did so he make sure that was
a specific one
he find out he looked at it and said hey
here we go so this is the one you want
this DVD this DVD this not not 80.
that's right so I said this 3D so my
thing is the interesting about in this
gospel is a specific gospel it's the
gospel
so we need to make sure what kind of
gospel is after because I'm sure you
guys know that it's a that's a lot of
different gospels up there yeah a good
point
yeah what you got many different
religions many different understandings
even outside the Bible so you've got
Nirvana right you've got you can reach a
state of being where you uh are are no
longer one with the physical world
apparently that's not the gospel that
the Bible is talking about you've got um
many different kinds inside the Bible
even that say Hey this is the way in
many different jesuses even it says and
that's that's a scary part because it
says which Jesus you know are you going
to follow so yeah and I remember we did
a LED show that this Satanist is say you
know what hey Jesus up here and tell me
about this and all the stuff and let me
tell you I mean I was a really shocking
Point like
uh we need to make sure we'd read our
Bibles to make sure it was the real
Jesus because let me tell you it's
appearing it's you know Jesus is
appearing or somebody said hey I'm Jesus
and I'm doing all this stuff and it is
only not only a hundred people is a
follower there's a thousands of
followers of that person that is is you
know they're saying that they're Jesus
or it's this gospel something like that
the gospel is really a message right and
and you know when you talk about many
different gospels there's a lot of
different messages I mean the snake in
the Garden of Eden was really giving a
different gospel at that stage then you
know God said hey if you do this there's
a consequence to that and this makes it
ah it's not going to be the consequence
it'll be this over here and so the the
the the false gospels that are preached
to humanity have always kind of been you
know is it speaking in line with the
word of God or not did God say that or
no yeah his gospel word you can be as
God you can be a god yeah that's
actually mimics some religions even
Christian religions say that you can be
a god which is kind of scary that's
right so that's cool right there so in
Revelation 14 6 uh it is an interesting
patches and you know as a prophetic book
and a lot of you know we understand that
prophetic you know Revelation is for
like the end times right the end times
and if you read the whole chapter 46 14
it's a specific message of Three Angels
right it's like a go to the whole world
to to tell like hey a warning message
let's pray that way so it says then I
saw another Angel flying in the midst of
Heaven having the Everlasting gospel to
preach to those who dwell in the earth
to Every Nation Thrive tongue and people
so again it's got to go to the world
yeah but what kind of is it has another
title that of the Gospel Everlasting
gospel
you know I I think the the the the
difference here in Revelation 14 of the
two gospels is you're going to have one
that's going to be teaching and the
character of the world and then you've
got one that's like don't have this
character you know you need to have the
character that is given to you from the
one that created the heavens and the
Earth you know that's great that's great
so the question I have for you guys so
what is the gospel you know we hear
about in this gospel specific gospel and
the end times we see you know these
angels these Messengers saying hey you
know what be careful the Everlasting
gospel so the question is basic right
what is the gospel what is the
definition
biblical definition
the gospel the good news good news okay
that God is saving us from our sin
I I would say that's kind of the central
theme of The Gospel is that it's not
just a saving from from Death so to say
but but actually a saving from your
sinful self which the result of having a
sinful life is death and he pointed at
me when he said that that we're all
going to die because we've all sinned
we've all fallen short and that's
inevitable but the good news is that
Jesus died for all those sins and if we
receive that gift then we can have
eternal life yeah amen amen so I just
want to share with you guys it's
interesting because when I say hey so
what is the gospel or what's the gospel
of preaching uh we need to back up what
the word of God says right and Matthew 4
4 says man shall not leave
by bread alone but with every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God so we
need to go back you know we need to say
the the Bible said this you know the
word of God said this thing yeah no what
I believe or somebody you know Pastor or
something I think that has a real very
real tangible like uh you know you you
aren't going to have everlasting life
because of some food you're gonna eat
but that actually comes from the gift of
God right so it's like something
spiritual that God is offering to us and
so I I see that that verse is so much
deeper than than you know you're just
you're just hearing the word of God it's
like you know the food is what you know
continues to give us life but you're not
going to live forever if that's all
you're you're focused on it's something
Supernatural That's given to you yeah
good right man
so and we found in the word of God a
definition I'm sure you know we say the
gospel you have the good news and you
know stuff like that that it's
interesting when when you had like a
definition like oh what what does this
mean it is this you know what is
television television is it is this or
is this right uh and Romans chapter 1
16. we found this powerful verse right
it said for I am not ashamed of the
Gospel of Jesus Christ why why not
because
for it is the power of God into
salvation
for everyone who believes so it is the
power
of salvation
salvation
to everyone
because
those one who believes
and my question for you what's going to
be in Salvation for what
you said it earlier salvation from our
sin yeah exactly so we're going to go to
Matthew Matthew chapter 121 when uh the
angel right he was talking to
Virgin Mary and it says and she will
bring for a son and you shall call his
name Jesus for he will save his people
from their sins from it's not in our
sense you guys want to share a little
bit what's the difference of insan and
Francine well you can imagine being in a
pool of water you're in the water you
are it stuck to you is water sticky it
actually is right when you actually get
out of a shower out of a bath out of a
pool it's all over you right you're
stuck in it it's say it's a sin sin is
stuck to you God wants to save you from
that he doesn't want to bring that back
into heaven right he doesn't want to
take sin into Heaven Sin was in heaven
at one time it was banished from Heaven
Satan and his angels were kicked out of
heaven so he wants to create in us and
that's that's what they call
sanctification in the Bible big word but
you're Justified when you come before
Christ but you're Sanctified which means
God's constantly step by step making you
better kind of like a plant I don't want
to take over the conversation yet but
this is huge because you have a little
say you have a little tomato plant you
just planted that plant how does that
plant look when it's growing it hasn't
produced any fruit yet but it's growing
up if it hasn't produced fruit you you
say this is a stupid plant I don't like
this plant no it's perfect as it is
right now and and as you're growing as
the gardener you want it to grow until
it produces that fruit at the Harvest
which is the second coming of Christ
Jesus says this in the gospel at the
Harvest he will take the fruits that
have grown he will take them back to
heaven and so right now we are all in
that process we are the crops and he
will take us home wow that's great I
love that illustration thank you Brad uh
interesting we talk about you know what
is the gospel and the definition of the
gospel stuff like that let me tell you
in Galatians chapter 1 6-9
Paul talks about hey be careful be
careful because there are some people
are going to come with a different
gospel so the Bible says that it says I
Marvel that you are turning away so soon
from him who call you and the grace of
Christ to a different gospel which is
not another but there are some who
trouble you and want to pervert the
gospel of Christ but even if we or an
angel from heaven preached any other
gospel to you that what we have preached
to you let him be a curse as we have
said before so now I say again and say
if anyone preaches any other gospel to
you that you receive let him to be a
curse I mean those those words there are
brave yeah harsh I mean very strong
words I mean would you like to be
occurred I mean because I mean that's
that's not not good so he's saying hey
you need to be careful even though maybe
it's an angel
show up to you in your house and they
tell you something and it's
wrong or against you what the world got
said and he said hey you need to be
careful that person or die and identity
that's not from God there's a danger in
in you know going back and looking at
what Adam and Eve had it's like God said
don't eat that fruit you know there's a
danger today of of really saying you
know how bad is really sin I mean you
know it's not it's not very bad come on
it's just one little thing over here and
you know the Bible is very clear the
wages of sin is death so to preach
another gospel that says you know oh
it's okay to have these things in your
life and and it's not really bad you can
have both worlds together that's clearly
not what the message was that God was
giving to Adam and Eve he did not say
you can eat of this and also you know
have eternal life it's like you know if
you eat that there's a consequence to
that and so I think that in that message
of of the Gospel it's like there's a
consequence to us choosing our own way
but God's offering us a way out of that
salvation out of that but we need to
surrender that to his way you know yeah
yeah totally so we need to be careful
how to share the gospel how to receive
the Gospel
and how to preach the gospel because
we need to make sure that we share in
the the right gospel right that's what
I'm trying to say
um no save us from in from our sins you
know in our sin but it's from our sins I
was raised in churches and watched them
on TV and stuff that was another gospel
I mean it was
Jesus and all these you know biblical
phrases were thrown out there but I
wasn't being taught what the bible
really teaches you know you know and I
was
yeah for for many years like eight years
of my life I was as a Christian eight
years as a self-professed Christian
didn't have the fruit because I wasn't
getting the truth you know but when I
started reading his word I changed
everything I I was hanging around with
Christians who were doing Bible studies
with me and they never had to condemn me
about anything there was things in my
home that shouldn't have been in there I
was me and my wife weren't married we
were living together I you know I'd have
a beer in my hand or drink or reading
the Bible or whatever they never condemn
me they love me like Christ and said
let's study the word and the word is
sharper than any two-edged sword I began
for myself to see be sober when the last
days Satan's like a roaring lion I'm
sitting here like I'm never sober
if they would have said hey man you need
to stop that I would have been like
there's there's something in us that's
kind of like uh we feel like don't judge
me or you worry about yourself or
whatever but when you see it for
yourself out of the word of God
that'll change your life and I think too
many times Christians today
they're not in the word they're just I
go to church on Wednesday I go to church
on set you know the weekend or whatever
but they're not really in it they're
just
the pastor's teaching them and you could
preach feel-good messages all day long
you know Jesus loves he wants you to be
rich and you're prosperous and all these
things to that church right yeah
but yeah we need to be in the word yeah
yeah totally so two things I want to
share with you guys uh in the Bible we
uh we we can read the story you know and
in Genesis the creation right I mean you
know God took you know six days to
create the whole world and the seventh
day he said you know why let's have a
little rest you know he blessed that
seventh day right so the creation who
created the whole the worlds right I
mean God you know the God Almighty uh
but also
the story of of Jesus how he came you
know as a baby and he was already
prophetic you know in in the book of
Isaiah I mean it says Hey from the
Virgin Mary from the Virgin
lady is going to be the the a baby right
and Emmanuel you know stuff like that so
it was prophetic stuff
let me tell you I'm going to share with
you guys how Hollywood is changing the
gospel and this is just one movie and
there are too many I don't want to share
you know three four or five different
movies because we don't have that much
time but I just wanna I just picked this
this movie uh it's called Clash of the
Titans
and I just want for you yeah maybe
you've heard that so uh please pay
attention pay attention you guys I don't
want to just share this clip just
because of the you know I used to have
fun whatever but just please please pay
attention that's the the power of media
how they change our our thinking you
know you know they put music they put
this thing nice word and Salah but pay
attention what they're gonna say and
remember you go to the movies
hopefully not but you go to the movies
and it's like what 24 30 frames per
second
and the whole message right please pay
attention the words of this the intro of
this movie
the oldest story is ever told are
Written in the Stars
stories of time before man and gods when
Titans Ruled the Earth the Titans were
powerful but their rain was ended by
their own Sons Zeus
Poseidon and Hades Zeus convinced his
brother Hades to create a beast so
strong and could defeat their parents
and from his own flesh Hades gave birth
to an unspeakable horror
the Kraken Zeus became king of the
heavens Poseidon King of the Seas and
Hades tricked by his use was left to
rule the underworld in darkness and in
misery it was Zeus who created man and
man's prayers fed the God's immortality
but in time mankind grew Restless they
began to question the gods and finally
rise up against them into this world a
child was born
a boy who would change everything
[Music]
Perseus okay interesting so we're
talking about you know I'm sure you guys
uh you read the book of Genesis right we
talk about you know how it was creation
and how Jesus it was you know more
and watching just this is just like a
couple minutes of the of the of this
movie I mean it's not two hours right I
mean it's just only the intro the movie
and as a Christian
believe the word of God right it's
solely true right that was so many
totally different gospel right there
yeah totally different how
creation story you know let's pray that
way so what do you guys think
I think it's fascinating that that you
know the devil doesn't like always tell
us just some completely different story
he loves to pervert the The Original
Stories and just tweak them just enough
so that the focus isn't really on you
know the reality of the situation and
and yeah I mean there's a lot of there's
a lot of parallels there yeah what in
the world is going on with with God
tricking Satan into going to hell I know
that's not who they were but the Greek
gods right Zeus tricking who was it
Hades into going and and taking the
other underworld what what yeah I mean
that I mean that alone makes you think
okay I get it yeah Zeus rules the
heavens that makes you think of God
right and then under the underworld that
makes you think of Satan but plants a
little seed in your head that says oh
yeah well it might have been that God
trick Satan that's why he's uh
it doesn't even rule the underworld
there's not on an underworld and so it's
it's all confusing yeah so that's why I
want to bring you guys just this movie
and you're interested in the end of the
clip a lady says that baby right and the
name is personally Perseus Perseus okay
Perseus it's interesting Perseus is the
the the the savior of the of the movie
right of the of this of the whole topic
but interesting that word it means
different things if you go to the Greek
and Latin the word means waste ravage
sack and Destroy so so just his name the
guy who's the saver
his name is means destroy and waste no
it's not like Satan and for them but let
me tell you the word I mean that that
meaning of a
of creation or this the Savior right and
that movie is destroyed I mean but in
the Bible it says no he's going to be
named Jesus he's going to be save you
he's going to be the savior of the
planet Earth but it's going to help you
to
uh uh you know saving for from our sins
so it's a twisting social thing yeah
exactly one it's gonna be the straight
one this one is going to be saving you
from your sins
in that movie right but it's interesting
and the Bible says in Luke 9 56 says
that for the son of man is not come to
destroy men's life but to save them
interesting I mean he didn't come to
destroy it he wants to save our lives
and John uh 10 10 is that the thief
comes only to steal and kill and destroy
I have come today may have life in a
bundling life so it's it's very
interesting how the enemies say hey you
know what let's make that movie about it
yeah you know it's a little twisted here
his the name the the how supposedly how
creation show up and and the babies show
up I mean I was the first time I saw I
was like no way I mean come on I mean
twisting a few things you know the
gospel uh Jesus you know how he's going
to come to save us and stuff like that I
have another clip of this actor I forgot
his name uh but he's gonna be talking
about about this Perseus you know how
his personality watches clip and then he
learns through his journey that he is a
he is the son of Zeus he's he's half God
and he decides to fight against it he
wants to be a man
and
defend himself and go through life as a
man and has no respect for these Gods so
what once again he will tell you he say
you know what he's Perseus guy is half
man and half God
you know he's kind of confused he
doesn't know what's going on and all
this stuff that's like a Jesus that's
what Jesus fully man fully God came as a
human
but this is not Jesus this is the
Destroyer yeah the Destroyer so it's 50
50. let's pray that way now 50 you know
but the word of God said no he was 100
many he was a hundred percent God
it's kind of Twisted there so that's why
we need to make sure you know uh what
kind of gospel we we we're reading and
the definition of the Gospel once again
I'm gonna go go back to Romans 1 16. the
Bible says that the Gospel of Jesus
Christ is the power of God through
salvation to everyone who believes so we
need to make sure what kind of gospel
are we reading what kind of gospel we
believing because let me tell you right
there in Hollywood different movies
they're going to be changing you their
mind and we know we're supposed in
darkness a lot you know our videos that
the enemy is right there just to so we
believe a different gospel but it's
gonna be to destroy not to save us from
our sins
so what is the gospel what is the gospel
and I just want to share with you guys
the Gospel of Jesus Christ is the God's
power to save us you and me from the
power and practice and penalty from sin
the practice the practice it'll save you
from something it's like
um you know if I were to save a child
from drowning in a pool it's like you
know you're you're bringing them to
safety so that they don't you know go
through with that there's a there's a
change that happens that word in the
gospel for power is dunamis in the Greek
and it's like the same power as like you
know
um Dynamite you blow something up
there's going to be a change a physical
change that happens and
um there's there's there's a change that
that comes along with what God is
promising you it's not just removing you
from that thing he's going to change you
so that you don't want to desire that
thing anymore right
yeah it's interesting like because I
think a lot of people think like I said
the little prayer
I'm gonna live my life and when I die
I'm going to heaven because I no one can
pluck me from his hand also there's a
lot of these verses where people try to
say once saved always saved I said the
verse nothing I do can jeopardize that
salvation which that's really not what
the Bible teaches but this says will
save you from practicing sin it's like
saying uh that Jesus came to save you
from getting fat on eating all that but
he's not going to stop you from eating
it you're just not going to get fat from
it so you eat anything you want to but
you're not going to get fat from it
you're really not learning anything it's
not going to change your habits it's not
going to transform you the Bible talks
about having a renewed mind being a new
creation having a transformed being
transformed but if you look and do and
everything just like the world you're
not transformed at all that's actually a
really good way to look at it um you
know the the idea of teaching somebody
to abstain from unhealthy eating or
something
um as opposed to just I'm gonna Shield
you from the consequence of eating that
all that way I'm gonna keep you from
getting cancer keep smoking yeah yeah
yeah exactly you know it's like go ahead
and continue to do this this this
activity that would be damaging to
anybody but just because you believe I'm
going to take away the consequences wow
yeah and people that believe in the once
they'd always say like you you say some
magic words and all of a sudden you are
going to be in heaven no matter what I
don't believe that because I read the
story of Saul Saul was chosen by God he
was the epitome of Saved I mean there's
no doubt about it people can say oh well
he wasn't really saved because he moved
on some anybody else in life well that
person they they started smoking and
they started doing all this other stuff
and then they died well they weren't
always saved Saul was saved he was
chosen by God and he chose not to be
with God when Samuel told him that the
kingdom was being rent from him and
given to another
um the words that he uses at that point
are your kingdom would have been
established forever God would not have
removed you nor your line if you would
have just done what he said and he chose
otherwise and God had to react to that
yeah there's there's scriptures about
you know please do not block my name
from The Book of Life and things like
that how can you and and
[Music]
um
prophetic verses in the New Testament it
says that many will fall from the faith
giving heed to seducing Spirits you
cannot fall from the faith unless you
were in the faith so there's a there's a
lot The Prodigal Son story you know he
was with the father he walked away from
the father when he came back the father
said my son was dead and is now alive my
son you know he's returned to you being
dead is a symbol for being unsaved being
lost but when he came back to the father
and the father willfully received him
back
he said now you're alive again you know
so there's a there's a lot of
um illustrations in the Bible about how
salvation is not just a one-time event
it's a lifelong growth die to the
yourself daily pick up your cross every
day and don't you want it like that yeah
I mean doesn't that seem like much more
of an opportunity that God is giving to
you to be actively involved in the
choice of what the outcome of your life
is like because it kind of sounds like
if you if you really believe like okay
there's nothing you can do to take this
away or anything that your action that
you're doing well isn't that kind of
this predestination I mean really isn't
that just like well God's already
determined who's going to go and who's
isn't going to go and you know by by
making the statement well you weren't
really on that team anyway to begin with
and and that's predestination to me what
difference does it make of your choice
rather than God is is is giving us the
choice choose you this day whom you will
serve you know and people are quick to
say Jesus isn't a religion it's a
relationship okay if it really is a
relationship that's something that's
supposed to grow and get closer and
closer if you marry your spouse and you
say well nothing I do is going to make
you leave me we're married I mean
you can't no one can put me from your
hand because we got a paper so I'm just
going to do whatever I want to do and
we're going to continue to be married
that's that relationship would fall
apart yeah yeah I used to be a part of a
a national Bible answers uh radio show
every week on Sunday I would go to this
thing and the pastor that was there
would always ask me we're in transition
between two different churches at the
time and um and so I wasn't attending
his church because he was transferring
and I was you don't know where people
are so he's always asked me every where
did you go to church this week where did
you go to church this week oh how was
your worships this morning and I always
thought that was a weird question how
was that what did he why did he ask me
that every time I go I mean why does he
well I guess he doesn't see me up there
anymore but why is he asking me that
well he later admitted to me he's like
he told me about other other
um
in private he says I can kind of tell
the
um spirituality of the person by how
their worships are going or how their
church if they're going to church
because what happened to Adam what
happened to Adam when Even Adam and Eve
ate the fruit they hid from God you go
away from doing worships you go away
from church you stop me and you stop and
you you step away from it and you hide
because God God wants to be with you but
you're the one that steps away and so
when you step away from it it shows your
spirituality that's a really good point
that's a really interesting point I
don't know I thought that was really
interesting and it it put kind of things
in perspective for me because I've
noticed in my own life
when I have not actually been as close
to God way back when I wasn't always
always doing my worships and and those
go hand in hand not only did I not want
to continue doing them but when I
stopped doing them I also didn't want to
be close to God that day so I I don't
know it's an interesting point that we
make those decisions and step away from
God it goes back to the power of the
word if you're in the word it cuts you
like a sharp two-edged sword and and it
changes your life yeah it's very
interesting what you guys said because
that's kind of exactly what I'm gonna
say in this comment because the gospel
is the power of God demonstrating our
lives and you guys life uh to give us
what victory over sin to the Penalty and
the power sin
so we need to because Jesus Paid our
sins you know he pay our sins in the
cross
I mean praise the Lord right amen but
what about this word what about this
question what about Temptations
I don't think it's a sin to be tempted
no Jesus Jesus is tempted yeah so I
think the Temptation that that we Linger
on and stay there rather than treat it
like Jesus did like he used the word and
then you know Satan was like oh yeah
you're gonna use the word I can use the
word too and he kept throwing the word
at him but he wasn't getting anywhere
and I I think it's interesting that
there's three times that Satan was
trying to attack Jesus and then after
the third he he had to leave resist the
devil and he will flee from you yeah I
don't think that that that that he is
able to just endlessly tempt you I think
he has to come away and come back and if
you're resisting that temptation
the only way to resist it is through the
power of the Holy Spirit and God but you
know how like siblings though mom he's
not flicking my ear or whatever just
ignore him and I'll stop and it works if
you keep flicking that ear and you're
just like yeah
yeah the person gives up because there
is no longer fun anymore they're not
getting a response so Satan keeps trying
and well nothing's working he'll come
back again at some of the time yeah but
but I I think that you know God God will
you know say okay you you get you gave
it a try back off he's saying no
yeah interesting uh because that's what
Mikey was saying about like you know I I
was I was safe you know in 1965 you know
I can do whatever I want or something
like that so that's why I have my
question I got saved since you know not
this via something like that but Jesus
gave us the power right there's the
power to give us to to have victory over
said amen so what about if somebody told
you to say hey we are going to be
sinning until Jesus come hmm
so it's a different gospel
well the Bible says in Revelation
in Revelation it says in 14 that there
will be Saints at the end of time that
don't see death
and that doesn't mean that they've never
sinned to up to uh their their
translation but it does mean that God
has worked in their life they have
worked so much that the demonstration is
the 144 000 that have no guile in their
mouth yes so there is a picture in
Revelation of a group of people that
that are at that point not this is uh
those who keep this is in Revelation two
there's three different times it talks
about those who keep the Commandments of
God
Satan is making war against those keep
the Commandments to God this is the
patience of the Saints who keep the
commands of God they're the ones who
have the right to the tree of life and
we'll get into the gates of the city if
you're keeping the commands of the god
you're not sinning
I mean right and so all throughout the
Bible you see that's will yeah have you
considered my servant job uh Moses he
kept his statutes and all these things
Commandments and statues we see it all
through the Bible where God was saying
this person keeps my Commandments and
there's there's Bible verses that say
you know he is able to
um that the idea that he has given us
the tools above and beyond anything that
that we can be tempted on we we have the
power to don't be tempted more than you
can and you can handle it that's how
it's worded and um also you know Jesus
said go and sin no more yeah he's saying
go and do this impossible thing yeah
you're never gonna make it yeah it's
interesting what you said because that's
the it contradicts what the Bible
teaches yeah I mean because if somebody
told you that kind of stuff I mean I
just want to tell you guys that is a
false gospel because let me tell you in
revelation 22 11 as says he who is
unjust let him be unjust still he who is
filthy let him be filthy still he who is
righteous led him to be righteous still
he who is Holy like him to be holy still
just like Brady was saying it is going
to be a time that God said you know what
I mean he he he's just yeah you know and
he's whoever is still practicing Unholy
things he's going to be doing it still
and I often hear people people say oh
you know I I you can't do that God you
know saved me in my sin and all this
other stuff but but they still believe
if you go into the conversation deeper
they still believe that there are things
that are wrong with Society hey should
you be uh doing XYZ porn for instance uh
no God can save me from that oh well
should you be murdering people no no God
can save me from that he can he can fix
that in my life what else can he fix in
your life how about everything God is a
powerful God
and so it is possible to live without
sin but we have to have that connection
with God and as time gets closer and
closer to the end there will be a
division of people that are for the
world and those that are for God it'll
be very evident can you imagine I think
a lot of its atmosphere I mean we live
in a world where you're buying groceries
and there's a half naked chick on a
cover of a magazine looking at you I
mean that without you even wanting to
boom you're seeing something now it can
trigger something but imagine if you
were living in a cabin in the field or
something
what temptation is there going to be for
you to sin like I mean so it is a lot to
do with our environment which I think is
why we're called to come out of the
Cities be in the country raise your
children in the country raise up a child
on the way they should go all throughout
the Bible people are being called out of
the Cities Sodom and gomor and all these
things because that's where the
Temptation is Sin City come out of there
come out of Babylon I've heard I've
heard people I I agree with you number
one I've heard people take it to the
extreme and become monks yeah if you're
a monk what are you going to be tempted
by but and they found out you know sin
exists in in the caves and stuff up
there too but I mean because it's a
spiritual war right right but it is
definitely less Temptation when you get
out into the nature you're not
surrounded by the concrete jungle of of
uh man's evil ways right remember well
this is the last verse I'm going to be
sharing with you guys well maybe a
couple more but uh it's interesting
let's go back to Romans 1 16 it says
because the Gospel of Jesus Christ is
the power of God to Salvation to
everyone who believes what does it mean
to believe it the Greek word I believe
there is pisteo I think and it really
means that there's some sort of action
that's attached to it it's not just like
I like like
that that belief the devil believes in
Jesus you know what I mean like the
devil knows who Jesus is the demons that
that where Cassie Jesus was casting out
came and said oh thou son of the most
high you know like they and they knew
and understood yeah and but they're not
going to be saved their belief that
Jesus is real did not cause a change in
their behavior and that word that is for
those who believed that word in the
Greek is really a change of your
behavior ordered after because you
believe who he is if somebody's trying
to sell you a product and they say I
believe in this product it works what
are you going to say prove it you should
demonstrate it on yourself exactly show
me some testimonies yeah you know so
you're not just going to say oh you
believe it works well give it to me then
I'll take your word for it no show me
that's so interesting what you guys both
you said because that's why we have a
testimony you know Christian testimony
like hey I can testify this thing you
know different action change my life
it's the proof the proof exactly and my
next my next verse in the Bible that was
James 2 19. you believe that there is
one God you do well even the demons
believe and tremble yeah uh you guys
stole my verse but it doesn't that
doesn't produce a change in them and I
think that's the difference the power of
the Gospel is is is you believing but
also because you believe your life is
now going to be different transformation
transformation yeah uh and this and
Romans 11 27 28 it says for this is my
Covenant into them when I shall take
away their sins as concern in the gospel
they are enemies from your sakes but are
touching the election they are beloved
for their father's sakes for the gifts
and calling of God are without
repentance for us you and times past
have no belief in God yet have not
obtained Mercy through their unbelief
and that verse and Romans 11 29 30 that
were believing
like you were saying like in the Greek
word and also it's interesting
you were watching my slides
it's about faith it's created it's an
action and also it is another word is
obedience like you were saying anything
action so if you tell it like hey go
shut the door it's obedience it's an
action like you go over there and it's
you do it you know and you do it with
love it's another thing about
relationship right if you love me keep
my commitments it's an action it's it's
obeying right so it's interesting that
word believing
and also can be with obey so I'm going
to just read this
now with the word not not believes now
it's obeying so in Romans chapter 1 16
says for I'm not ashamed of the gospel
of Christ for it is the power of God of
salvation for for everyone who obeys
that's fine so it's it's the gospel is
right there it has power but how are you
going to get the power how are you going
to get the power and a lot of Christians
say well you know I mean I've been doing
Christian for 20 something years that
I'm happy power for this thing whatever
but there's another one that you need to
be obeying you need to do the action you
need to say yes Lord I can do whatever
you know with your strength I remember a
friend of mine Eric Wilson he he first
um um kind of started teaching this
concept of really learning to read the
Bible in promise form and and he said
you know read the Ten Commandments in
promise and I was like what do you mean
by that like like how do you how do you
read that and he's like well if you read
it like God's promising just to if you
live your life according to him or let
him be in the driver's seat you won't
have another God before you I promise
you won't take my name in vain I promise
you won't
um you know defile my Sabbath I promise
you you know that that changed the
context for me I'm looking at it and
going wow like the power of the Gospel
is really God promising that we're not
going to engage in this sinful Behavior
anymore
take away you you read the verse take
away when you take away the sins that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean the
consequence that means you took that
thing out of my life you know I don't
want to do it anymore it's almost like
wedding vows you know and do you promise
to cherish and to hold for Better or For
Worse thick and thin and you're like you
look at these Commandments like yeah
we're in a marriage covenant with it
with Jesus I will not
commit adultery on you I won't have
other gods I won't take your name in
advance I love you why would I do that
I'm going to spend a day with you like
date night
that's pretty cool yeah yeah well I just
want to say thank you guys for uh
hanging out here with me and I thank you
guys I hope you were a huge blessing
there's a little bible study about be
you know just be careful what what
you're watching seriously because the
enemy is using media especially all the
stuff and you know there's some movies
up there that maybe I mean they're going
to be changing you the idea of the true
gospel please uh hang out here with us
with another uh conversation with
another videos we have a lot of
different topics uh check out our videos
thanks so much for your support and and
patreon I really appreciate it because
without you guys we cannot make those
videos available and it's and it's not
it's not only uh one video a week we
we've been working so hard to bring more
videos so uh thanks so much for your
support and also uh uh check our
different links uh and our friends and
thanks so much for your donation we
really appreciate it and we'll see you
next time with another another video
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you